[Music]
food
is a universal language it has the
capacity to bring people together
and that's exactly how we got the
seniors who stay alone in the marine
terrace estate
to venture out of their homes and gather
in a space
to cook and eat or what we call in relay
makan
together as one big family
[Music]
when our client monford care coached us
to design
a senior activity center we come to
appreciate that singapore
is facing a silver tsunami with one in
four singaporeans projected to be above
the age of 65 years old by 2030
[Music]
we took this as a challenge to re-look
at the existing model of social support
and reimagine the role of the senior
activity centre and through design and
programming
we tackle not just the existential but
more importantly the emotional needs of
this senior in a purposeful and
meaningful way
good life narcan is unlike any other
senior activity center
here the community kitchen is placed in
the heart of the facility
it invites the seniors to be active
stewards of their own community
by helping themselves and providing for
others through food
instead of using muted and neutral
colors we went with bright colors to
enliven the center
and to debunk the association of aged
leaving
in a muted and sterile setting the array
of full height glass doors
stay open to create a welcoming and
porous space
for all residents
it's been quite refreshing and
encouraging to observe how this shed
facility has fostered bonds
between seniors gulaf makhan has given
this seniors a newfound sense of purpose
and ownership at the center now that's
the recipe for good design
you